uh-huh okay no it starts okay look we
welcome to this video playing either
call mr. so colon let's see what he
plays actually playing a normal mainline
ya wouldn't expect that from him usually
is I want to play something weird okay
okay Quincy to him you can probably
start with the smooth and b3
ok let's go back there prophylactically
try it for 925 here
okay if you trade this bishop i think
i'm going to take myself and then go 9
p-5 he will play Knight f3 I assume
interesting interesting hmm yeah
probably will he's got potentially a for
of course but this is something where
I'm not sure if this helps helps really
or not we j5 is interesting as well
Quintus III try to undermine the pawn
down as usually as usual it gets
answered quickly okay so what's going on
here 94 to put more pressure on this I'm
not sure and that actually looks good
there do have something something better
something technical this already looks a
little bit strange for wine if you ask
me maybe just a simple move I don't know
okay it's not spend too much time I know
the deal at the end we would have some
sometimes scramble and he will swindle
me out of a good position so let's play
let's play quick
probably swing out of a good position is
a weird way to put it but yeah I have a
good position he swindles this is
usually how he wins so oh I didn't
actually want to go there that was a
mouse lip basically maybe it's not so I
wanted to go to before I was just anyway
it doesn't matter position is not that
bad no I'm not bad at all actually ok
let's go here and now it's an
interesting moment here I have five here
this is an interesting idea I'm not sure
about it though i also have g5 as an
interesting move I think I go g5 just
see if I can keep keep the keep tonight
ok so 85 maybe now night c44 while yeah
that that's possible no
I always have an extremely difficult
time to guess any of his moves one of
those people I thought Nazi force force
almost any way if it isn't just doesn't
matter um if I go a4 yeah maybe maybe he
can play some take at a 3-yard this kind
of thing I don't know
ok so here I mean I can no come cut keep
it simple just take the better ending
and be okay with it I'll try to again
more other probably loose on time
someone so need to treat the bishop to
make any headway maybe this may not show
all right doesn't do all that much
wanted to prevent you to be seven it's
difficult to and need to trade the
bishop somehow otherwise hosn isn't weak
enough
hmm I wonder if he can somehow enter
from the back and irritate me yeah he
tries so I don't get this route does
bishop traded I mean this looks dull
like a dummy a piece on c4 but it keeps
everything together
yeah I'm not sure every before it's
doing something probably not much
okay so we get 11 traded how does that
work out here this is probably a draw is
ending I go through it just like that we
made I'm always amazed I mean this is a
super borderline ending time morning for
white and you just goes for it got
everything on light squares myates
probably should be winning somehow all
right I can't I get this passer I have
maybe not winning but it's very close
cat this one maybe you can just sit and
wait in this position that's possible oh
now now it looks no it looks suks one
like this is this as this is wearing now
my cat this is it
nope removes white eyes I yeah I can
come around here to a four and then
promote upon a very strange player and I
don't get it sometimes like this step in
in a second to go in the lost to two
lost ending maybe you have maybe had to
I don't know what so okay let's have a
look at this we start out so this is a
fairly fairly normal line I retreated
voluntarily now to make way for for the
night here um and so I think this is
normal night a for it was interesting
trading this training the bishop it's
interesting stop Fisher suggests f5 now
this is something that I have recognized
while studying the bangko that the
computer is very much liking f5 and some
of those positions to undermine the d5
pond it's a very interesting strategic
idea that um I mean I was well that but
I was surprised how often the engine
likes this it's something that it's not
an easy move for me to make because the
the King position gets weakened quite a
lot so I decided to play more in a more
conventional way the engine see wants to
play a five okay I don't think this is
particularly bad now this was allowed
quite quickly yet here I wasn't sure NAT
D fraud doesn't look like the best move
but I had to make a decision night h5 is
given by the engine it doesn't seem to
like this one all that much rookie one
okay
hmm surprise that I should be worse in
this position maybe he gets in five and
yeah this is possible that if I've is
coming quickly hmm but let's say I take
ha play Knight to d7 it's that bad that
is a bit like the game just a little bit
better for wide in comparison I don't
think this is so bad so that's so
terrible him 85 is coming home okay
maybe Queen g7 yeah but I'm Calif agree
maybe this is a bit better for white it
shouldn't be terrible for black but why
does a bit better of course this is
probably a slightly better version of
that now I did want to Blake whenever
six but it probably isn't that bad I
wanted to go here actually but ok
somehow that mouth slipped to have six
yeah queen bee to uh I was also
surprised I thought you would keep the
Queen's on I mean here yeah I'm
definitely okay f5 was also interesting
here but I wasn't sure about all this
like if he goes at 4i go back and then I
don't know this is looks a bit murky my
my development it's not good if I would
be better developed I will have like 10
more well g5 is also a good move it it
just keeps the night only five and I was
always thinking you should play Knight
c4 at some point but he never did
somehow they form takes class chicks
yeah so here I was actually I did not
play that well I should get more here
this position is very good and you see
that stop fish agrees here with 0.8 but
I did not when the computer wants to
play at six king of 7 h 5 h 4 okay but I
saw 11 idea in the lines that is really
interesting bishop c8
and Bishop a six and it's a good idea I
would like to trade the bishops I know
that his bishops look stupid but if I
trade the bishops I may I have full
pressure against the a pawn yeah in the
game you always had this Bishop
protecting it and I can still do those
invasion ideas my pony is just a lot
stronger as a protected passer then a2
which is just a weakness so this was
interesting to put the bishop around I
mean this this wasn't particularly
terrible but i'm not getting getting
done much whoopsie three years was
supposed to an interesting one I played
it somewhat on a say on the safe side
because well time and so on so takes
takes over here miss kingly for which
seems to be a already very decisive yeah
but I saw that this come and in town how
can you take now in a second I mean this
ending is super borderline probably he
has to yeah I can see maybe he has to
wear this also looks bad but I mean here
this is this is I don't really think
that you can save it the computer goes
f5 also interesting also very
interesting and five
I went I'm sorry I went age for first to
fix ji tun and played with e6 yeah the
problem is he will probably have to f5
it will probably get suits one taking um
he cannot take if he takes a loose t
five so he has to move the bishop
somehow I all set f4 maybe at maybe f4
is actually a problem also and then just
entering a 6 e 6 is the engines okay it
wants to play hmm and it's very strong i
mean there's this idea and then then
taking four here and here yeah he's got
our hands on haight squares this is why
it was extremely surprising to me that
he took this ending so quickly the other
might be might be losing as well but I
mean this f5 seems stronger than but I
really think that this should win as
well and I think the engine I am
basically agrees yeah I'm super swinging
him now yeah and resigned it if it moves
like this I go around he has no no move
here ok guys thanks for watching